got a crazy question for you what do you
think Trump and Obama have in common or
maybe even Elon Musk and Steve Jobs
Trump and Obama you may say they have
nothing in common
all those four have one thing in common
they all know exactly their style of
selling and it's not the same Trump
doesn't sell like Obama Elon Musk
doesn't sell like Steve Jobs but they
were all able to get results whether you
agree with them or not because they know
they're selling Style
if you are not getting the kind of
results selling it may be because your
style doesn't fit your personality if
you want to find out what sales style
fits your personality click on the link
above or below go take the quiz to find
out exactly what's your selling Style